happy hour last 24 hours on Cinco de
Mayo especially at El Dorado Cantina so
Kyle vinceum is here with a big Fiesta
invite it's all going down tomorrow for
this at Tivoli Village at all three
locations all three locations oh shoot
but the block party is that too block
party is a typical Village okay okay
excuse me all right my bad I know this
is a this is serious how do you guys
prepare for Cinco de Mayo do you drink a
lot of water today you gotta make sure
you're hydrated for the next day for
sure
um preparing uh it's a huge uh it's a
huge Testament we we're testing
everybody we just want to get through
this and make it work for everybody well
you guys know what you're doing it's El
Dorado Cantina so let's talk about this
block party first and foremost because
this is the big big Fiesta what's going
down so we close down the streets we're
doing it tonight
um you can see us there at 11 o'clock
tomorrow all the way through until 11
o'clock uh PM as well wow that's so cool
we're gonna have a taco tent we'll have
a beer and Margarita tent nice we're
gonna have a DJ from three to seven
we'll have a live band for me to 12. of
Don Julio uh ice luge inside
and uh it's going to be a great time
oh okay this is very Vegas of you guys
okay so you know at Tivoli Village are
kids invited to this Fiesta of course
it's a family it's a family thing of
course yes okay good good now let's
let's get into this because I've been
this like guacamole guacamole the whole
time I've been standing here and I'm
ready do you want the best tableside
guacamole you don't have to go to El
Dorado Cantina for it I've already got
the garlic and salt in there but we're
gonna go ahead and add the rest of the
ingredients to it okay okay Tomatoes is
the first part it's so simple everybody
so simple it's not that simple though
it's a secret oh excuse me okay yeah I
mean you know it's
it doesn't take much so then we went to
onions Serranos Serrano's based on how
spicy you want it to be a little bit of
cilantro on top there
now let's make sure we get the lime
now do you now should you make a
reservation at any of the locations so
at this point we basically are fully
packed okay um if you can find a
reservation through open table or any
other Outlet you're more than welcome to
uh I we suggest there might be some
cancellations so hopefully come on over
hope so I hope so but the greatest part
about it is you want to do it go ahead
yeah mix all together can I do the
honors 100
some drink specials too right drink
specials as well so we got Don Julio
over here they're going to be
representing uh our Sammy Davis location
we'll have Margaritas flavored and
regular also Palomas uh and then we'll
have Casa Amigos at our Center Point
location and artillery location you'll
see the same drinks there as well
uh and then our Patron is going to be
sponsoring our ice luge for us should
mix it all together voila the best parts
at the end just gotta do a little
topping to decorate it boom and I would
say the best part is eating it that's it
do you would you like to I'm ready I'm
ready now thank you again to El Dorado
Cantina for sponsoring this segment they
have three locations in the valley for
reservations and more visit Eldorado
cantina.com or visit the phone number on
your screen I'm gonna dig in and we will
be right back